co-directing as husband and wife is that
possible I mean we lived to tell the
tale we're still married we had a child
afterwards so yes I think it really
helps if you have have complementary
strengths so we had a kind of a division
of labor from the very beginning I was
in charge of the visuals and pretty much
everything except acting and Thomas was
to be in charge of the actors of course
those lines totally blurred on set I
think if we ever get to make another
movie we'll try and separate a little
bit better also just have more support I
mean part of the reason I got blurred is
you end up doing like ten jobs each and
really I mean it was great that we were
both there because it was constantly
some other job oh yeah we're like how
the hell do people do this as one person
this job is so hard and there's so many
things to think about what it makes a
lot of sense to co-direct and because
there was two of us it allowed us to one
of us could be aiding or could be doing
whatever needed he done and that I guess
if you don't have it you just don't have
it that doesn't get done it was it was
hard though it was so hard oh my god we
didn't fight but we we kind of
compartmentalized during the shoot and
then add ones of resentments and pain
suffering and suffering the unpack yeah
but we tried to hold it together during
the shoot mostly because which we sort
of did let's be honest a lot of people
want to kind of see you fail as
co-directors I think and and there was
definitely some pitting against each
other and his first-time directors yeah
yeah yeah so we really tried to always
present a united front you know as much
as possible oh yeah and actors are the
worst you can't trust them they are the
worst they are tricky they are so tricky
and when it's night shoots and
everyone's tired everyone revert back to
their five-year-old cells us included
and yeah yeah yeah
there were some dark dark dark days dark
nights at the side yeah well knowing
that anytime there's a group endeavor
there's always going to be that married
or not so how do you know when it's just
I'm just let a certain topic go and let
the other person quote unquote win like
let them have their way and when do you
say you know what no I really want this
and I'm going to fight for it you know
we honestly I think we're both two very
reasonable people so there's that but we
we just always kind of see eye to eye
there weren't a lot of times where we
disagreed about things yeah it's truly
almost always agree we almost I think
some people's partnership is good
because they constantly fight about
stuff and they constantly but for us
it's not but we did have some moments
like we did have not we had moments
where because we're both so reasonable
when one of us did put up a fight about
something and it was the middle of the
night and we were trying to stay on
schedule it became really difficult to
take a step back and say okay are they
putting up a fight because they're
losing their mind and they're too tired
or am I not putting up a fight because
I'm losing my mind and I'm too tired
like trying to find the reason in the
middle what I discovered about halfway
through with that I was always right and
that that was actually the what we
didn't know at the time sorry yeah
goodland he's never right
you